yeah welcome to this video but latm
playing and blitz game against money
enough from yeah no idea where from okay
the cow can advance with a quick c4 this
is uncommon the idea causes some as well
known Missy for usually white plays aged
form
beforehand and only then advances okay
like some place of course sent it around
the d5 square the system very nice
square to have but White has this idea
and now that I think of it maybe maybe
maybe I should have waited a moment hmm
yeah f5 f5 is quite quite substantial
here
and yeah maybe he can play it anyway and
then Queen f3 or something hmm
yeah dangerous maybe I should have
waited a moment with 95 so that out if
the night would have been on his seven
still I would have haven't had night at
five and he wouldn't have played a four
then in the first place this is some
looking a bit tricky okay so at least
I've got a temple now on deform it looks
a bit weird to move that to this piece
again but I don't really want want f5
maybe this is too much h5 okay so night
here very shaky position
my development is not exactly great yeah
no wonder I played 95 and 97 back hmm
okay if it takes Bishop takes an IG
three that's Bishop g4 and an aged form
so maybe this is still okay the only
thing saving me from complete explosion
yet is that I have this d5 square rather
firmly blockaded my dream maybe I even
have Bishop d3 could be an idea maybe
this is too ambitious but I always I
always have a Bishop g4 this isn't bad
on 93 Majesty would have but the idea is
that we should move some rods player 5
but I have Bishop g4 with the temple and
yeah now I can at least grab this Knight
maybe I should I'm not sure yeah come on
dig this night not having a knight as
some form for white a slight problem
here because the knight is the piece
that could easily exploit those holes g
5 f6 and so on and this is now a very
young very block position rook e8 and
something
now looking at first then 95 I always
want to be able to capture with the
piece so what now I can try to get the
King to g7 when I said something else
can I improve okay get the King to g7
first his pieces are not exactly well
placed for g-form h3g for wood would
have would be a plan but he's got all
the rooks on the Kings side so not
likely to happen okay so maybe he tries
to regroup
I came what I'd like to do I'd like to
get this Bishop to b6 attack the pawn
maybe it's too ambitious I don't know
he's regrouping I'm not really sure I
understand how he regroups most doubling
on the C file I don't know I'm not quite
sure what this is doing the blockade on
d5 is very nice but the night isn't
attacking anything so this is why I'm
thinking about this regrouping okay okay
g4 but if I take a play Bishop H father
should be a good response meaning that I
cannot go B should be six I mean I can
but okay let's let's let's wait for a
moment
if you really plays g4 and have this is
a gem
now it's e7 to b5 is another idea
mmm
yeah I'm not sure at all who is he's
coming here it's got a five okay but
this I need to do anyway aha maybe he's
threatening gt5 now cutting off cutting
off the little bishop
okay but I think I always should have
sacrificial ideas g5 Queen e7 and then
second g5 should be something
yeah very difficult to play this
position I made many moves that don't
look like I have a plan that this is
probably true okay now I'm trying to get
this SEC going here but some I'm pretty
much forced to do that okay
should I SEC now I could also now it's
not exactly threatening to to trap the
bishop can first double here
can move the Queen may be mentioned
sweatin to take on g5 now it's going
back interesting ok cannot be bad to
double on the edge for it is very slow
ok now now let's take it it's certainly
dangerous at least that he's got 20
seconds on the clock
no jack this one was hanging couldn't go
Jack yeah what now
I'm just a man exchanger two pawns up
Jack let's exchange white resigns a very
difficult position very difficult at one
point I wasn't mostly just moving around
because I didn't know what to do around
him it was a bit shaky this is opening
but here black Bishop should be quite
solid but then yeah I had this this idea
what just isn't too bad maybe at least
it's an idea and then he came up with
this and I wanted to have to shop age 4
so I basically am
yeah cancelled this plan and put it all
back yeah this this this was an idea to
attack it maybe it's bad I can because I
I never really can take it but I'm not
sure okay so this was clear and then he
went for for this car cut off with g5
but I have I have this straightforward
plan of just taking on g5 and
after he lost those moves I'm not sure
it looks very dangerous now the I mean
it's not quickly threatening to trap the
bishop CIN is really working at a
computer also gives me a direct win here
yeah I thought it was at least with 20
seconds on his side it was good but it's
also just just just to win interesting
alright thanks for watching